well believe it or not almost three
years since the UK voted to leave the
European Union people have elected a new
set of MVPs to the European Parliament
there will be 73 of them in total
representing the nine regions in England
plus Scotland of course Wales and
Northern Ireland with each electing a
different number of MEP s depending on
the size of their population now in
England Scotland and Wales people vote
for a party party's rank their
candidates in order and seats are
allocated using a calculation meant to
ensure a more proportional outcome it's
called the dhondt method I'm sure it's
your favourite electoral system it
certainly is mine now Northern Ireland
though uses a different system where
voters can choose 2nd and 3rd
preferences at last European election in
2014
voters took advantage of the
proportional system and while as you can
see that they punished the main parties
you Kipp did exceptionally well in those
elections they got 24 MEP it was the
first time that a party not the Labour
Party or the conservative party had won
a national poll in Britain here through
100 years the governing Conservative
Party back in third place with 19 seats
labour got 20 seats UKIP's leader then
of course was well who else Nigel Faraj
the ghost of the feast and this time
he's back with an uber exit party and
poll suggests he could have a similar
impact I think it will be very important
for him to try and beat the total of 24
percent or so that he got back in 2014
now he's standing in the southeast but
in the southwest
we've got region has attracted most
attention we've got some high-profile
candidates political celebrities if
that's such a thing including Rachel
Johnson four remain supporting change UK
the former tory minister and widow
command the brexit for the brexit party
and lord andrew adonus for labour and
while the UK voted on thursday polls
don't close in europe in some countries
until 10 p.m. tonight here they all are
like a weird Eurovision there are 751
MEP s all in all each EU state elects a
different number all according to their
population all the way from Germany with
96 they've got the most all the way down
to Cyprus Luxembourg and Malta all with
six apiece they sit in different groups
based on their values in European
Parliament rather than their nationality
so we've got the Social Democratic group
the EPP that's Conservative Party's
really liberal parties Euroskeptic
parties the Greens who look like they
might be having a good night tonight but
no single group in 2014
a majorette majority in the previous
Parliament at looks likely to be even
more fragmented this time